the tree spirits and you're saying your
grandfather. Go ahead.
>> Tree spirits. Um and so my grandmother
went out into the forest where that tree
was and this long tongue comes out of
this tree, she said, and it scared her.
And she goes back to my grandfather
saying, "One of your tree spirits scared
me. Like, you know,
>> get it checked."
>> Um but
>> yeah, I grew I grew up with that story
being told multiple times by my mom. How
how even with with nature right natural
things how do they I I don't know uh
manipulate
>> the Bible tells you that
>> sister the Bible told you that spirit
creatures have power to cause tsunamis
storms
cause earthquakes and cause people to
get sick and heal them. It's in the
Bible. That's not shocking. I'll show
you.
Let me now show you systematically
everything that I claim from the Bible.
The gods of the nations, they exist, but
not as gods. They're demons pretending
to be gods. Let's take it step by step.
You ready?
>> Yes.
>> All right. Here you go. I want you to
see 1 Corinthians 10:20. Why does Paul
tell the Corinthians who used to be
idolattors and converted, "Don't go to
the temples. Don't offer sacrifices to
the gods." Why? The idol isn't anything,
but there's a demon attached to the idol
here. 1 Corinthians 10:19-21.
What do I mean then? That a thing
sacrifice idols is anything or that an
idol is anything? No, it's an idol, but
it's not the idol. It's the spirit
attached to the idol. No, but I say that
the things which a gentile sacrifice,
they sacrifice to demons,
not to God.
So the spirits out of trees and the
spirit Those are demons. They're real.
So that's what your grandfather is
seeing. That's what your mother is
seeing. Demons. But they don't know
demons that they're demons because they
don't they don't know the Bible. They're
not Christian. All they know is these
are just spirit beings who want to do us
>> good. That's the deception.
>> Yes.
>> And I do not want you to become sharers
and demons. See, when the Gentiles
sacrifice to these gods and goddesses,
they are empowering demons to control
their lives and work through them and
eventually oppress them. You cannot
drink of the cup of the Lord and the cup
of demons. You cannot partake of the
table of Lord and table of demons. Now
the one of the oldest translations of
the Old Testament, Hebrew Old Testament
into Greek was done by a group of Jews
about 280 years before Christ. Watch how
the Jews that translated the Hebrew Old
Testament into Greek understood
who these gods of the nations were.
Watch here. Psalm 95 verse 5. So I'm
going to go step by step and show you.
And what about trees? And oh, the Bible
has the answer. The Bible tells you that
angels, right, whether righteous or evil
angels, because what are demons? Fallen
angels, evil spirits, Satan, fallen
angels, have power over the elements.
They can cause
storms. They can cause tidal waves. They
can call cause diseases. I'm going to
show you. They have those abilities. So,
we go to Psalm 95:5.
The gods of the nations, what are they?
Psalm 95:5. Here you go. We go right
here. Verse five. Here it is. For all
the gods of the heathens are devils.
But the Lord made the heavens.
Ironically, the word is demonia, where
you get demons. Demonia. Now, why is
that ironic? See, the Bible tells you
these are devils. These are demons.
They're evil. However, here's what's
amazing. Did you know that even the
pagans acknowledged the existence of
what they call demon demon
but they didn't think they were all
evil? In fact, believe it or not,
Socrates claimed he had a demon that
would inspire him to compose his
philosophy and it was the demon that
told them they're about to kill him.
Did you know that Socrates also used to
have epileptic seizures caused by the
demon, but he didn't think the demon was
evil? The word demon for them did not
mean necessarily an evil being. It
simply meant a muse, a spirit guide,
right? Demon demon, right? Demons. And
he even said, "The spirit would appear
to me. The spirit would give me my
philosophy. That's why he was so
brilliant." And the spirit warned him
they're about to kill you. So he died
without fear because he knew he's going
to die. Why? Because the spirit told
him. Now had you asked Socrates, you
know that's an evil spirit? He'd laugh
at you.
You understand?
>> Yeah.
>> He'd laugh at you because why? Why is
the spirit evil? He's done nothing but
bless me and he's done nothing but gone
out of his way to look after me.
Right.
You with me there? So, they're real. The
Bible says they're real. Now, how do I
know they have power over the elements?
That they have power to get you sick,
cause you disease, or heal you,
right? And manipulate
the elements. Well, here, let's go to
the scripture again.
Let's go to Revelation
7. Now, these are righteous spirits, but
I just want you to see the principle,
right?
All right.
>> Yep.
>> All right. Watch here. Revelation 7:13.
After this, I saw four angels standing
at the four corners of the earth,
holding back the four winds of the
earth. Now, who controls the winds?
The four angels, right?
>> The angels.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So that no wind would blow on
the earth or on the sea or any tree.
Then I saw another angel sending from
the rising of the sun having the seal of
the living God. And he cried out with a
loud voice to the four angels whom was
granted to harm the earth and sea. So
wait, they have power to wreck havoc on
the elements, what we call natural
disasters. They're not natural. They're
either caused by direct invention of God
or spirit beings
saying, "Do not harm the earth or the
sea or the trees and to have sealed the
slaves of our God on their foreheads."
So if they have control over the trees,
why do you why are you shocked that they
can manifest through them?
>> See how the Bible has all the answers?
Are do they already have do they already
have that ability or does it need to be
granted by God?
>> No one has an ability if God hasn't
given it to them. Where do you think you
got your ability? Your ability to speak
and think and act. Where do you think
that came from?
>> Yeah, I guess it's the same.
I kind of answered myself.
>> Where would an angel get an ability if
he wasn't created with that?
>> Where do you think the ability came
from?
Yeah. From God.
>> The question is, what are you going to
do with the abilities and talents that
God gives you?
>> Yeah. For good or for bad.
>> In fact, let's just look in the human
realm. Every amazing human being who has
been gifted in whatever area that blows
people's minds away because it's a
talent gift that's unparalleled
and it just defies
our
senses to see how is this person able to
do what he does. whatever field it is,
music, a voice that shatters glass,
let's say, or a chess player where a guy
can play 50 people at chess blindfolded
and wipe them out. You understand what I
mean? Or these people who are phenomenal
physical specimens that do physical
feats that blow the mind away. Let's say
like Bruce, whatever it is, all of these
people have been endowed with these
abilities from God.
The question is, what are you going to
do with those abilities? Are you going
to use them to praise yourself, prop
yourself, bring attention to yourself,
cause people to idolize you, point them
away from God, or you going to use it to
bring glory to God?
The way Bruce Lee moves, one of my
heroes, he was breathtaking to look at a
young guy to move with that kind of
speed, mind-blowing. But that was
because God gave that ability. or
Michael Jordan, the way he would suspend
in the air. This is my day. I don't know
if you know. He It's like he was flying.
He would jump from midc court and he
would be floating in the air.
Something that was mind-blowing to look
at.
Or Mariah Carey who can sing at such a
high pitch she shatters glass
voice is angelic or this is all from
God.
This is not something they got on their
own. God endowed them with ability. And
here's an ironic thing. This is also
documented. Have you heard of people
selling their souls to the devil?
>> Selling their souls. Yes.
>> Meaning entering into a covenant with
Satan saying, "Look, if you uh give me
this ability, then I will give you my
soul." You'll hear stories of guitarists
or magicians or even singers
making a pack with the devil. People who
had no talent all of a sudden
are amazing and doing things that they
were not able to do and doing things on
a level no one else can compete because
they sold their souls the devil. Now,
what does that tell you about Satan? He
has the ability to make you sing at a
pitch or play guitar. And if he has this
ability to do things through you if you
sell yourself to him.
So what does that tell you about the
abilities of demons of angels?
And I'm going to show you that from
scripture. But here first of all who had
power over the four winds to harm trees
or not to harm them the four angels.
Right?
>> Mhm.
>> Earth seas and trees. So who who has
ability to cause a tsunami? Angels have
that ability. Cause earthquakes, angels,
right? Tornadoes, angels, right?
Manifest through trees or manipulate
trees. Angels right here. Also,
Revelation 9:18-21.
A third of mankind was killed by these
three plagues. Now, we're going to see
where the three plagues come from. By
the fire and the smoke and the brimstone
which came out of their mouths. You know
whose mouths? Demons.
The context on about demons.
Demons were here. Let me show it to you
because I have the entire chapter. Yeah,
because see sometimes I got to give you
because you may have not read this. But
anyway, here
>> Revelation 9, an angel came down, a star
came down from heaven, was given the key
to the abyss, the shaft of the abyss. He
opens up the abyss as a spirit realm.
Well, demons are imprisoned. When he
opened the abyss, watch what happened.
Then out of the smoke came locusts upon
the earth, and power is given them as
the scorpions of the earth have power.
Notice these are not physical creatures.
They're not physical scorpions. They're
spirit creatures coming out of the abyss
that look like scorpions,
look like creatures that you see on
earth, but they're not. Look at their
power. So, so when when you have flies
manifesting in people's haunted
demonically whatever uh manifesting
houses or
things coming out of the mouths of
severely possessed demonically possessed
people that that is an ability of that
demon to produce these things that look
like flies, that look like frogs, that
look like
>> Well, let me read it to you. You're
going to see how they look. Watch here.
Then out of the smoke came locust. Wait,
they look like locusts.
Right there.
Your answer is right there. But they
came out of the abyss. They're not from
the earth. But a swarm of locust came
out.
So your answer is right there in the
Bible.
Are they real locusts or they're just
>> If they're a real locust, you can squash
them like a bug.
What does that mean? They
look to us as locusts. That's their
shape. So when flies come out of
people's mouths, where do those flies
come come from? Well, there were no
flies. They didn't come out of his
belly. Those are demons appearing as
flies.
>> Wow. Interesting.
>> How did the flies come out of their
mouth? that came out of their belly.
What do you think that is manifesting?
>> Yeah, it makes sense when you put it
like that.
>> Yep. So, when swarm of flies come out of
nowhere out of the person's mouth, those
are demons manifesting as insects.
>> Wow. Wow.
>> Scorpions insects.
Aren't locust insects? That's what we
classify them, right?
And you know what? One of Satan's names
happens to be
balob. The lord of the flies.
>> Right. Yeah.
>> He's the lord of what?
>> The flies.
>> All right. Let's continue.
Then out of the smoke came locust upon
the earth, and powers was given them as
the scorpions of the earth have power.
St. Lord, they're like scorpions.
And they were told not to hurt the grass
of the earth, nor any green thing, nor
any tree, but only the men who did not
have the seal of God on their forehead.
So they can harm the elements.
They can harm grass, trees, or
vegetation.
They have that ability.
>> Interesting.
>> Do you see that? I mean, I got to make
sure.
>> Yeah, I see it. I see it.
They were not permitted to kill anyone
but to torment for five months. So they
can even kill you dead. But here God
says, "No, all you're going to do is
torment those who hate God, blasphe God.
That's their punishment." And their
torments like the torment of a scorpion
and it stings a man. That's how it's
going to feel. In fact, they will
torment these unbelievers to such such a
point. They want to die to get the pain
over it, but they won't be able to. In
those days, men will seek death and
never find it. They will long to die and
death flees from them. Okay, now watch
their appearance. The appearance of the
locust was like horses. Oh, so they look
like horses.
And on their heads appear to be crowns
like gold. And their face was like the
face of men. So bodies of horses face
like men. Look how deformed and
grotesque they look.
>> Yeah.
>> But look, they have hair that looks like
the hair of a woman. But their teeth are
like lions.
So why would you be shocked that demons
would appear as flies?
>> Crazy.
>> But it gets a little deeper.
And they had breasts placed like brace.
I know Ezekiel 28:13 doesn't prove your
point, buddy. Don't misquote. I'm going
to send you to Mike Winger. And the
sound of their wings was like the sound
of chariots of many horses running the
battle. They have tails like scorpions.
They even have tails.
What a grotesque looking being. body of
a horse, has a tail, teeth like a lion,
face like a man, hair like a woman.
They have wings of iron, right? Or wings
that are strong. But anyway, and their
tails is their power to hurt men for
five months. They have as a king over
them the angel of the abyss. His name in
Hebrew is Abaden. And in Greek, he has
the name of Polyon. But now watch the
power
right here. One woe was passed. Behold,
two woes are still coming after you
things. Then the sixth angel sounded and
I heard a voice from the four horns of
the golden altar which is before God.
One saying to the sixth angel at the
trumpet, "Release the four angels who
have bound been bound at the great river
Eup Euphrates that's in Iraq." The four
angels were released who had been
prepared for the hour and day and a year
so that they would kill a third of
mankind.
>> So they have power to kill. And the
number of the armies of the horsemen was
200 million. I heard the number of them,
right? And this is how I saw in the
vision the horses that and those who sat
on them. The riders had breastplates the
color of fire. Now he's not talking
about human soldiers. He's talking about
demons,
demonic being beings unleashed on the
earth and of hyasin and of brimstone.
And the heads of the horses are like the
heads of lions and out of the mouths
come fire and smoke and brimstone. So
you see these demonic horses, demonic
beings can even breathe out fire.
A third of mankind was killed by these
three plagues. By the fire and the smoke
and the brimstone which came out of
their mouths.
So who can bring about deadly plagues?
These demons. For the power of the
horses is in their mouths and their
tails. for their tails are like serpents
having heads and with them they do harm.
So it's not talking about horses we see
on earth. These are demonic spirits that
look like horses
being unleashed on the earth.
>> So do they do some of these demons
possess these abilities even now or
haven't changed?
>> Who told you that changed? Wow.
In fact, my understanding this is a
future event. Hasn't happened yet. And
then the rest of mankind who are not
killed by these plagues did not repent
of the works of their hands so as not to
worship demons. See, notice what it's
saying. Mankind,
unbeknownst to them, are worshiping
demons whom they think are gods and
goddesses. Here's another confirmation
that what Buddhists are worshiping are
demons, though they don't think they're
demons. Yeah.
>> And idols of gold and of silver and of
brass and of stone and of wood, which
can neither see nor hear nor walk. And
they did not repent of their murders nor
of their sorceries. Now, I'm going to
blow you away the word sorceries. So,
these people who are worshiping gods and
goddesses are really worshiping demons.
When they go to idols that they fashion
after gods and goddesses, they're
worshiping demons who are appearing to
them as those gods and goddesses. But I
want you to catch something.
They did not turn away from murder,
sorcery or sexual morality. It is a
common motif,
common practice among pagan religions.
The sacrifice of humans, human
sacrifice.
The Mayans did it, the Aztecs did it,
the Greeks did it, the Babylonians,
Canaanites did it did it. especially
child sacrifice where they would offer
their children as a sacrifice to the
gods such as Bal or Molech.
>> You're aware of this, right?
>> On hot coal.
>> What's the name of the god that they
sacrificed to? What did you say? Oh, on
hot coal. Yes. I'm sorry. But they said
hot coal. All right.
>> Yeah. Yeah.